Let's go next to our caller from the three
zero eight area code.
Who is calling today from three zero eight
Hey, can you hear me?
Yes I can.
Who's this?
This is Kowalski from Nebraska.
Hey Kowalski.
What's up?
Well, I just wanted to call in and say, uh,
I will actually, I was just kinda curious
last year the Midwest received like record
flooding and I was just curious how much that
like hit the radar of people who live and
you know, the more popular areas of the country.
That's a good question.
I'm trying to think Carl recall story.
I mean I remember hearing about flooding here
in, in from here in Boston, but it was certainly
not like a major story.
But you know, part of that may be I don't
really watch sort of like regular news where
you just get, you know, a breakdown of what's
going on in the news.
I'm pretty narrowly consuming political news,
so it also may have been that just in my circles
it wasn't being talked about as much, but
I, I didn't hear that much about it.
I admit.
Hmm.
We did have like a dam failure and stuff and
unfortunately it's looking like we're not
going to have that great of a spring, so we
might be looking at some flooding again.
But I was just generally curious how well
that hit your radar.
And also, I recently talked to some people
from the Austin area working on some agricultural
software and stuff and they're pretty swell
people that admit you guys have some pretty
nice folks in the neighborhood.
Yeah, I mean, is there the belief in Nebraska
that people in Boston are not nice?
Well, uh, I'm more
from the rural area of Nebraska, so I'm not
like Omaha or anything.
I'm central Nebraska and there's kind of that
feeling of love, uh, the coasts or ignorance,
so to speak.
But I got to say these people had really,
you know, just open minds and were very compassionate
and I generally liked them.
That's fascinating.
So there's a stereotype, rural central Nebraska.
Well, hold on a second.
You're shot out of a cannon today.
In, in, in central rural Nebraska.
There is a stereotype that the people on the
coasts are the ignorant ones.
I'm ignorant of agriculture.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Got it.
Um, yeah, like, uh, there's this idea that
goes around that, and actually to be fair,
they get admitted to this, to that, uh, many
generations removed from agriculture, don't
really understand like the processes and stuff.
And I had to admit before going to like the
university, it was kind of an eye opener to
me how limited people's knowledge of like
agriculture is, but you know, you are your
environment, so it just makes sense.
Yeah.
I grew up in Western Massachusetts where there
are a lot of farms, but they're, they're relatively
small.
It's not the large scale farming that you
see, uh, you know, in other parts of the country,
including the Midwest and in the central California
Valley
just has that gravitational pull of, you know,
with being just deep dominant and history
and everything.
So it just does overwhelm your whole life.
But I'm not really an active listener of your
show.
I watch a lot of it in passing.
Like, you know, some of the stuff you put
out, I think you do some good work and whatnot.
So yeah.
Let's just keep up the support there to the
folks in Iowa and make sure you give those
folks a call and I hope you have a good day.
Hey and listen, how rural is your living situation?
Like how long of a ride is it just to go to
the grocery store?
Um, for me it's not too bad.
Um, I live outside of a, uh, it's actually
the largest city in Nebraska's third district,
so I only live like a few miles away, but
I've got a lot of friends and we do a lot
of business and like some of the more rural
areas.
And I got to say, um, okay, just, uh, so you
know, I am a registered Republican, although
I would consider myself more of a radical
Republican, so to speak.
I generally am like just somebody who thinks
that if you're going to live here, go with
the dominant party and do your best to make
it moderate.
Does that make sense?
I understand what you're saying.
Yeah.
But, so you were talking about how rural it
is.
Yeah.
So like, uh, where I'm at isn't actually too
bad because I am close to a larger community
of like 55,000.
But a lot of the areas I go to and where a
lot of my friends are from there, they do
not have those luxuries or like they have
to travel a couple of hours to go to the stores.
You've got basically food deserts and uh,
the big problem we are facing is a medical
care.
Yeah.
Like a problem is you can't really have a
heart attack in the middle of nowhere cause
even a helicopter will still take, you know,
two hours to get you where you need to be.
So that is one thing.
Like I have been telling a lot of people around
here that, you know, Sanders plan for Medicare
for all does include like just straight up
subsidies for rural communities to have clinics
to have full time nurses and whatnot.
And that would go a long way of also bringing
outside resources to help revitalize rural
America.
So I keep telling everybody, you got to take
a pipe issue by issue basis.
You know, so like when it comes to healthcare,
Sanders clearly blows everyone out of the
water, but, uh, you know, it just depends
on your priorities, but I would say,
yeah.
All right.
Kuwalski you're starting to break up, so I'm
gonna let you go, but I appreciate hearing
from you and [inaudible]
for a super interesting to hear from someone
in relatively rural Nebraska.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up because I
will go right back to his bones after this
short range.